welcome back everyone we are all trying
to stay cool during this heat wave but
how do the record-breaking temperatures
impact your health
if you have heart problems well joining
us with some insight here at noon
is interventional cardiologist dr
anthony dota good afternoon to you
doctor it's great to have you
hi alex thanks for having me thanks for
making time for us wanted to ask you
first you know people with heart disease
are at a higher risk
for heat stroke why is that yeah um
you're absolutely right we know that
patients with certain cardiac conditions
like congestive heart failure heart
artery disease
and certain valvular conditions seem to
suffer from heat stroke much more
frequently than people without those
conditions and
what we what we found is that patients
with those conditions have a more
difficult time
dissipating heat from their body because
they're unable to sort of shunt
blood flow appropriately to the skin to
get rid of some of that heat and
perspire
like normal people would be able to so
not only do they get this condition
more frequently but when we do see cases
in patients with underlying cardiac
conditions
they tend to have more severe
manifestations of the heat stroke as
well
i think we've all heard about heat
stroke how dangerous is it
um so yeah so heat stroke that requires
hospitalization
um is a very serious condition and um
there are some case series that report
mortality rates as high as 20 percent um
so it's important that if you recognize
that that's what's clinically going on
with the patient
to seek medical attention to to get
appropriate therapy for this
okay so with that in mind what should
you do if you have underlying heart
condition someone watching right now
and the temperature say is above 90 or
even 100.
yes so you really have to be cautious
when the temperatures outside exceed
what your normal body temperature is
which as
most of us know is around 98.6 degrees
so
um in las vegas we we typically tell our
cardiac patients to avoid being outside
during the
hottest parts of the day and during this
time of year that's really from about
noon to 6 pm where we see the hottest
temperatures and
if for any reason you're uh you know
unable to avoid going out and being
exposed to these extreme temperatures
you know wearing loose light-colored
clothing can help
um staying in the shade obviously just
some of these sort of
common sense things and you know staying
well hydrated as well so
drinking both before exposure during and
after um whether you're thirsty or not
can help
prevent one of these problems before it
happens absolutely
and so what are the signs of heat stroke
what should we look out for
so um you know obviously the increase in
body temperature which people feel as a
subjective fever is
is the biggest thing uh and what we
typically see is you know
lightheadedness
uh nausea muscle weakness
severe generalized fatigue uh and then
the actual heat stroke uh
entity people get neurologic dysfunction
so um
you're seeing people that are confused
or have slurred speech or or can even be
comatose so
that's where that sort of stroke portion
of the of the term comes from so those
are the things that
that are you know should be alarm
symptoms to seek medical attention
yeah really important things dr anthony
dota thank you so much for
all of your advice and for making time
for us we really appreciate it hey
thanks for having me it was my pleasure
stay safe
you too and thank you for all the work
you've been doing the past few months i
know it's been
it's been hard so thank you so much